The History of English in Ten Minutes.
Chapter Nine, Internet English or Language Reverts to Type.
In 1972, the first e-mail was sent. Soon, the Internet arrived.
A free global space to share information ideas and amusing pictures of cats.
Before the Internet, English changed through people speaking it.
But the Net brought typing back into fashion...
...and hundreds of cases of repetitive strain injury.
Nobody had ever had to download anything before, let alone use a toolbar.
And the only time someone set up a firewall,...
...it ended with a massive insurance claim and a huge pile of charred wallpaper.
Conversations were getting shorter than the average attention span.
Why bother writing a sentence when an abbreviation would do...
...and leave you more time to "blog," "poke" and "reboot" when your hard drive "crashed"?
"In my humble opinion" became IMHO, "by the way" became BTW...
...and "if we're honest that life - threatening accident was pretty hilarious"...
...simply became FAIL.
Some changes even passed into spoken English.
"For your information",...
...people "frequently ask questions" like,...
..."How can LOL mean 'laugh out loud' and 'lots of love'?"
If you're gonna complain about that, then UG2BK.